phasmes black creek est pour la deuxième
année consécutive le parc france
miniature à elancourt accueil lopy
l'office pour les insectes et leur
environnement avec un tout nouvel
atelier
les familles ont pu découvrir plusieurs
types d'insectes aux déguisements en
particulier mais qui présente certains
inconvénients on ne met pas avec les
autres fassent mieux parce qu'en fait
d'autres fassent ne crois que c'est une
feuille banquise et de grignoter ne sera
pas du jour la matière feuilles en goût
que ce soit l'exposition se présente
comme une mini maison des insectes avec
des terrariums des vidéos et des
activités de recherche dans la faune du
sol l'occasion d'appréhender le monde
des insectes pour comprendre leur rôle
qui sont très importants pour le
renouvelable de la matière organique
comme de la transformation de la matière
nous organiser en matière minérale la
pollinisation grâce à pas vous manger ça
à pas vous tuer juste s'émerveiller
c'est très sympa ça permet de découvrir
plein de petites bêtes
à trouver des larves de mouches des
cloportes des je sais plus comment des
mollusques et puis les enfants adorent
moi j'adore aussi donc voilà on s'amuse
bien
les parents ont partagé un moment de
loisir avec leurs enfants et se sont
prises au jeu